yannick nézet-séguin on vous attrape en
pleine répétition à la salle bourgie
pour une captation de concert de l
orchestre métropolitain
les concerts qui vont être diffusés sur
le web seulement c'est une expérience
assez inusité comment vous vivez ça
premièrement je pensais le bonheur de se
retrouver qui hélas cette semaine même
en distanciation on avait pu constater
que finalement quand on ose quand on se
donne quand on se connaît quand on quand
on est concentré il est peut-être même
des avantages à avoir chacun son propre
du train je sais pas il ya des musiciens
qui préfère presque ça à cause de la
pandémie tout est arrêté dans le monde
de la musique classique
ça a été difficile pour des musiciens
d'un orchestre métropolitain qui sont en
fait des pigistes des travailleurs
autonomes pays pour chaque concert est
important pour vous de vite vous
remettre en selle et refaire des
concerts
c'est sûr que l'insécurité pour tout le
milieu culturel parce qu'à peu près tout
le monde dans les musiciens c'est
l'immense majorité qui est travailleur
autonome
donc effectivement il n'y avait pas de
sécurité là et quand ministère de la
culture annonce est dédé
des mesures en ce qui nous concerne et
c'est exactement ce dont on avait besoin
pour laisser nos projet prendre vie
prendre forme de façon pouvoir donner du
travail de musicien parce que c'est ça
notre responsabilité est aussi aux
pigistes qui se rajoutent qui sont même
pas membres de l'ocs est c'est notre
façon de fonctionner il ya encore
énormément d'insécurité il ya d'autres
ensembles pour lesquels c'est plus un
secure mais se réinventer pour moi c'est
pas réinventer notre façon de jouer du
violon c'est réinventer un contexte que
six mois c'était par les est ce que
c'est possible et yannick de jouer à
deux mètres de disques en chacun sait
jamais mais là si c'est ça que ça prend
pour qu'on joue mais pourquoi pour puis
finalement on apprend des choses sur
nous mêmes l'opéra de montréal annuler
ces deux productions de l'automne le
metropolitan opera de new york
aussi et vous êtes directeur musical du
maître sadek un choix déchirables de
tout annuler comme ça ce c'est
horriblement fait la réalité à new york
est évidemment différente d'ici alors je
pense que c'était la bonne décision pour
la santé la sécurité de tous
mais chez moi je vis ça très durement
évidemment parce que je sais à plusieurs
vitesses fo veut comme si vous imaginez
moi je suis d'un côté avec le
gouvernement puis à voir comment ça se
passe ici pour pousser au québec puisse
une réalité très différente du
gouvernement américain qui n'aide pas du
tout les arts
à ce niveau là et ça c'est des donateurs
mais si on parle aussi de de plusieurs
dizaines de millions ce qui est pas la
même réalité qu ici donc de voir mes
musiciens de leur caisse du met et les
musiciens et les chanteurs du choeur du
maître qui sont en fait en arrêt de
travail complet c'est très difficile
mais je pense quand même que l'espoir de
recommencer le 31 décembre
c'est quelque chose de réaliste
restons aux états unis parce que toute
une discussion présentement sur le
racisme systémique depuis de la mort de
john floyd
bon alors qu'istres de philadelphie que
vous dirigez on vit au modjo d'embauché
pour la première fois dans son histoire
une musicienne noire qui s'occupera de
la bibliothèque musicale l'orchestré
métropolitain compte un musicien noir
mais est ce qu a encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire la musique classique
oui beaucoup de chemin à faire et c'est
important dans une ville comme
philadelphie que l'orchestré soit plus à
l'image de sa communauté et c'est aussi
tout à fait un hasard que on est cette
nouvelle fantastique musicothécaire
nicole jordan qui est la gagnante d'un
processus sur plusieurs mois que
commencer bien avant les récents
événements alors on peut se dire
évidemment c'est terrible ce soit la
première musicienne noire on a eu des
musiciens noirs mais la première
musicienne
oui c'est pas c'est pas suffisant et
cette question là me passionne beaucoup
parce que je pense que c'est la question
de l'éducation qui est vraiment à la
base alors dans leurs caisses par
exemple on dit toujours les auditions
sont derrière rideau alors que le
meilleur gagne
on est juste femmes hommes peu importe
l'origine c'est vrai qu'on est juste une
personne qui cherche à ne pas engager
quelqu'un de couleur ou d'une communauté
culturelle différente mais c'est pas
suffisant parce que qui se présentent à
nos auditions qui étudient dans les
grandes écoles qui se rend aussi loin
parce que qui a cette passion-là dès
l'enfance
donc évidemment je suis pas content de
ça c'est pas quelque chose dont le
milieu classique et fier où
d'être aussi en retard mais je suis
heureux que la discussion finalement
s'ouvre c'est maintenant et comme obama
lé disait récemment c'est c'est à nous
le faire c'est pas les paroles on
n'attendra pas c'est pas une prochaine
génération
c'est simone et moi je veux évidemment
dans toutes les institutions faire ma
part pour que ça ça se produise
maintenant c'est très beau merci
beaucoup
yannick merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]